high drama in Washington as Robert
Muller breaks his silence the special
counsel making his first public
statement since taking over the Russia
investigation two years ago on collusion
Muller says there was insufficient
evidence to prove a broader conspiracy
between the Trump campaign and Russia
and when it comes to obstruction mother
says that charging a president with a
crime was quote not an option his team
could consider he explains why if we had
had confidence that the president
clearly did not commit a crime we would
have said so we did not however make a
determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime under
long-standing department policy a
president president cannot be charged
with a federal crime while he is in
office charging the president with a
crime was therefore not an option we
could consider it would be unfair to
potentially accuse somebody of a crime
when there can be no court resolution of
the actual charge but if you are now
left with more questions than answers
didn't expect for that to change at all
Muller also shutting down Democrats
calls for him to testify on Capitol Hill
I hope and expect this to be the only
time that I will speak to you in this
manner I am making that decision myself
no one has told me whether I can or
should testify or speak further about
this matter
there has been discussion about an
appearance before Congress any testimony
from this office would not go beyond our
report beyond what I've said here today
and what is contained in our written
work I do not believe it is appropriate
for me to speak further about the
investigation or to comment on the
actions of the Justice Department or
Congress president Trump reacting saying
the case is closed
tweeting quote nothing changes from the
Mullah report there was insufficient
evidence and therefore in our country a
person is innocent the case is closed
thank you White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders also responding saying
quote the special counsel is moving on
with his life and everybody else should
do the same but as you can imagine
McCrea leaders including Jerry Nadler
and Nancy Pelosi are still out for blood
as Muller again highlighted this morning
it falls to Congress to respond to the
crimes lies and other wrongdoing of
President Trump with respect to
impeachment question at this point all
options are on the table and nothing
should be ruled out nothing is off the
table
we're legislating we're investigating
and we are litigating no one is above
the law especially the President of the
United States I am gravely disappointed
in the Justice Department for their
attitude their misrepresentation of the
mother report to begin with
despite Pelosi's disappointment Muller
said Attorney General Barr acted in good
faith with his handling of the report
Geraldo III look at this thing and I'm
more confused the country's more divided
I don't think he added any clarity to
his already confusing four hundred page
report you know I always liked Muller
for his gravitas and his dignity he
always seemed to me to be a
straight-shooting guy and I have no
reason to to change my opinion but I
want as a lawyer to analyze what he said
because I think it's very important he
sets a new low bar right in terms of
what is you know where the criminal
culpability begins he said if we had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so the implication is Muller thinks
it is possible that the president
committed a crime so this is a brand new
level of evidentiary you know
requirement it's not probable cause that
a crime was committed it's possible that
the president committed a crime it's
possible that I'm gonna grow another
inch next year it's possible that you
know I'm gonna play for the Boston Red
Sox I think that it is really it was a
gratuitous statement reminded me a lot
of James Comey when he screwed Hillary
Clinton in 2016 I I don't know where it
came from it's almost as if he had to
say something because he wasn't accusing
the president it came directly from the
report so and I think was the March
twenty third or so when the report came
out and Bill Barr provide us the summary
not the whole report the summary that
line was in there is actually in bill
bars original letter it that exact line
that if they could have done this they
would have done that so I actually think
Jesse there's a lot I think there is
more clarity here I think that it shows
a lot of the the report is the report
you can read it or not I mean sometimes
a little bit of this stuff because we're
not lawyers on all of us it's like
reading through gauze like wait what
does that mean whether I actually think
that what Muller was saying is don't you
can subpoena me but if I come up there
I'm just gonna tell you to read the
report everything that he said today is
actually in that report so I think that
he tried to really color inside the
lines he didn't try to go out of it
there is one other thing though there
was this question all day long whether
there was a discrepancy between what
Bill Barr said in terms of this
obstruction case and in that point and
what molar said today later on very
unusual for the Buller team they release
a document and Jerry Dunleavy at
Washington Examiner shows it showing the
molar quote and the bar quote and
basically saying there's no discrepancy
here they don't go that and say there's
no discrepancy here but there's more
context and a source close to the
officials at the molar team said they
don't think there's any conflict or
daylight between molar and bar which I
think is very good news if you're the
Trump team but wouldn't it seem like if
you know because I read the statement I
have the transcript because listening to
them was very confusing to me he says
defendant is proven innocent unless and
until proven guilty okay and then he
says we couldn't determine one way or
the other whether the president
committed a crime therefore the
president must be presumed innocent well
okay
you know what what was interesting about
that contradiction was he was first
talking about the Russians he was saying
their emotions get the better they get
the benefit of the doubt but then he
moves on to the president and he
basically said he's guilty until he's
exonerated but we're not going to do any
process of exoneration so I gotta go see
you later I'm out of here so what do you
I know the Trump isn't above the law of
the print but he's also not below the
law either so you can't be Prince you
know you know if you're not gonna
resolve this you just can't throw that
out there I felt I mean you know he was
supposed to be the dad
that went that went upstairs to lay down
the law to the kids okay no more pillow
fights lights out everybody go to bed
that was kind of his role and instead he
just walked in with a crater ritalin and
threw it at him and said have at it for
the next 18 months I mean to say he
couldn't say an uncharged person was
innocent I mean he also okay if you if
we can't say he didn't do it that's the
same as saying we can't say he did do it
so just let it go I think that he was
goaded into doing this right it was nice
men or the media I think the median the
Democrats forced his hand and he had to
go and do this this is now the fourth
bite of a rotten apple right the first
was a summary that came out that media
spit it out then the second was the
release they spit it out the third was
for having Barr come on they spit that
out now it's got this presser they're
not gonna be happy with this why do we
keep indulging this itch I hope you're
right I hope it's over
but the meeting the Dems are just gonna
suck this out well I do think the media
in the Democrats obviously the Democrats
I'm sure going to talk about that they
are going to pursue it but there was
nothing that he maybe he didn't have to
give this statement today but nothing he
said today was not already in the report
and he's also saying I'm done office is
closed yeah this thing is through
Kennedy I think that he should have been
more forceful and I think he should have
outlined if there was something that the
president had done that was so illegal
untoward and if he were a private person
would have been charged with a crime he
really should have laid that out and
there's a difference between describing
someone's behavior and applying some
sort of discipline for that behavior and
yes I understand he said you know under
long-standing department policy of
President cannot be charged with the
federal crime while he is in office
that's fine but there's precedent for
this you have two other similar criminal
investigations that led to impeachment
where they were much more forthcoming
with the acts that the president
committed while in office and the other
thing and and I wish he had been more
clear about that because if the
President had done something so bad that
this was now past the Congress then he
should have crafted a much better Road
man he could have said that he could
have said you know we're not charging
him and and here's why but he said he
could have said this president did this
and I believe he's guilty of this the
way Ken Starr did with Bill Clinton yeah
that would have would have taken the
bite out of in the report I think what
he did was instead summarize ten legal
theories for a possible obstruction
charge the end of the day he didn't say
the president obstructed justice the
other thing and her all that was right
you have to start with the presumption
of innocence that is the legal system
that we have in this country whether you
like it or not no matter how bad the
crime is that someone has committed and
here at like in gymnastics you don't
start from zero and build your way up to
a ten you start from a ten and work your
way down that's the opposite of how it
works here here you start you are
assumed to be an innocent person and
then you build a case upon that and
Geraldo's right like it is conceivable
it is possible that Donald Trump
murdered fifteen old ladies okay all
right well maybe not that many old
ladies maybe just a few shows it by the
way all right
we're not we're a deal with bowling you
start with zero and then you get a
strike which is ten if this was cards if
he'd Muller dealt Pelosi appear reduces
mmm she's holding a pair reduces now do
you go forward with impeachment with the
pair of deuces he left her with two
numbers for technology reduces good do
see still she left a memo to Jews